Alright guys so in this video I'm going to talk about confirmation entries and I did
not make a video about confirmation entries in the you know my course videos so I thought
maybe I should share it with you guys and it's helping me a lot it help it has helped
me a lot and it's also going to help you a lot with the with your win rate okay so you
are going to miss the trades sometimes but when you're going to take those trades they're
gonna actually work out so let's take ABC as an example so let's say that you are looking
at ABC right on a five minute time from so you have these small little pullbacks then
you have this one large pullback then you have this big pullback oh sorry push up again
so textbook ABC right we have taken out the high so then on the five minute let's say
we are looking at the five minute time from right so on the five minute we have a market
structure shift right following all the rules so you would have your favorite gap or
autoblock marked up here right so now when you have your favorite gap and autoblock marked
you want to drop down to the one minute time frame or a smaller time frame right and this
was on the five minute right so when you're going to drop down to the one minute you're
going to see a structure like this right so on a smaller time frame like one minute
you also wait for market structure shift okay through your POI so on a bigger time frame
we have ABC right and then we have a market structure shift on a bigger time frame once
you have market structure shift and you mark up your POI you want to drop down to the smaller
time frame and wait for fractal confirmation all right you want to wait for confirmation so
on the one minute you wait for market structure shift again with displacement and I'm going to
talk about displacement in the coming videos so then you take your entry from here right after
market shift you take your entry and this is going to increase or win rate because this is
confirmation right that the autoflow is now bearish so you can target something like this
and can work out when you are not using confirmation entries what sometimes can happen is
you know you have your ABC and you have broke the structure price can simply just
stop you out okay so I think it's better to look for confirmation entries right when you
have your ABC setup you wait for confirmation on smaller time frames so let's say that you are
looking at the ABC on one hour time frame and you have your market structure shift right and then
you have your POI on the one hour time frame you want to drop down to the five minute time frame
and then you want to look for a confirmation like this right so you have a break on the five minute
time frame and you have your free body gap or OB here and then you take your entry from this level
put your stop there and kaboom so this can be used with any strategy that I've taught you guys
so let's assume that we are looking at the autoflow trading strategy so on the one hour time frame
we have you know like a change of character here or market structure shift whatever you want to
call it and then we have our autoblock here so when when you have a market structure shift what
you want to do is you want to drop down to a smaller time frame like 15 minute or five minute
I would say drop down to 15 minute right so you would have a structure like this then
and then you wait for market structure shift on a 15 minute time frame right you break the
structure on the 15 minute time frame remember we had a change of character on a one hour time
frame and then we had air confirmation from the POI or from the one hour POI on the 15 minute
time frame so when you have a market structure shift you can just take your entry from this level
here and you go along here and you put your stop there and kaboom it's going to work out in your
favor so what it does is first of all it just gives you a better risk to reward entry and
secondly it increases your increases the chances of that trade going in your direction so
you want to consider using the confirmation entry tactic in your in your strategy
now this is gonna take some back testing because for some people this might not be suitable because
sometimes what price will do is let me draw this out right so you have your POI here right so
let me draw this out so what's going to happen is you're going to get your confirmation
market structure shift but price will not come back to the lower time frame POI your entry point
and it's just going to keep on going up so this can happen and you are going to miss out the trade
but what is what's beneficial what's the plus one of this thing is that you're going to get a better
risk reward and you're also going to increase or win rate so make sure that you take this into
consideration also a lot of people mess up this one thing so you want to go to the indicators and
type in and type in ICT Killzone right so you are going to have like Killzone what is Killzone
is like the London session and the New York session and there's specific timing that you should be
using for your trades because at that time is when the algorithms are active right so you're
going to have a Killzone London Killzone and then you're going to have a newer Killzone I'm going to
I'm going to show you the indicator as well that is going to you know show you the Killzones
so your entry must be so you have like you know a break of structure here so now let's say sorry
change of collector market structure shift you have market structure shift here right so what
you don't want to take your trade outside the Killzone you want to take your entry
during the Killzone hour so let's suppose this is London Killzone right so you have your entry and
boom similarly over here you want to wait for you know the price to give you the entry during
your during the New York Killzone so this is a must thing and a lot of people mess this up they take
trades during long during a wrong timing and it could be the reason why the trade doesn't work
out in your favor so in this lecture what I've taught you is a confirmation entries right and
I've also taught as the Killzones how they are beneficial for your win rate so if I go here let
me go to the five minute time frame I have the yeah so there we have our Killzones you can see
this is the London Killzone right and this is the New York Killzone that you are looking at
so your entry must be between these hours right it's that simple
so you can see that actually for indices personally I would still be looking to trade till before
take my entry before 11.59 right but over here this Killzone indicator says then 10.40 and also
I see this is actual this is an actual Killzone right which ICT teaches but for indices you can
go till 11.59 if you get actually I would correct myself there I messed up
when the clock hits 12 on indices if you are in a trade you should close it immediately because
price can reverse all right so the best time would be till 11.30 if you get your entry at 11.30 that's
prime okay you don't want to hold your trade till 12 you want to close it before 12 so yeah
make sure you know that so yeah I'll end this lecture here and we'll continue with other
tactics